there's no one in our team thinking
score a winning goal no one can be
you know you've just got a goal you're a
leaf is enormous and the second goal
goes in
and literally i'm planked on the floor
on my back
literally i think i actually nearly went
into tears
[Music]
my first ever experience was
actually
arriving at the team hotel for my debut
i don't even remember the first training
session but i remember being involved in
the squad before torpedo moscow which is
my debut at the age of 17
and i remember turning up at the hotel
and i remember it was the midland in
manchester in the midland in manchester
is a grand old building one of the
oldest hotels in manchester probably the
most famous
and
thinking i've never stayed in a hotel
like this in my life
ever
you know i
you know we've been to tenerife on
holiday or
blackpool or fleetwood and stayed in
caravans on holidays and literally to go
to the midland hotel i thought oh this
is a bit posh and i was sharing with
chris casper i was in the youth team
with and then he told me i was going to
be sup and i i couldn't believe it that
i was going to be sub and my mum and dad
would come into the match
and i remember warming up thinking he's
not going to put me on and he put me on
with three minutes to go and i touched
the ball once it was a throw-in sort of
epitomizes my career
my career continued on that path of sort
of inactive average
but it was it was the most incredible
experience i always remember getting my
dad getting quite emotional on the way
home and to this day i always say it was
the most important moment in my life
when alex ferguson speaks to you and
there's nothing there's none of these
like sort of great speeches
this is what it's gonna be like to play
for manchester united tonight it's very
understated when you're breaking into
the team
i'm gonna put you on the bench tonight
son and then you'll go is that okay i'll
go yeah thanks and that's it you know
it's not like this sort of major
monumental moment he wouldn't play it up
he wouldn't build it up so you get more
nervous you know i remember my brother
played his first game in manchester
derby
and he didn't tell him i don't think
until
maybe the earliest was the day before
maybe on the day of the game he even
told him
because if he told your three four days
before you've got three or four days of
nerves of anxiety and build up and
what's going to happen so you always
left it quite late understated and made
it very normal like any other game of
football
were you scared
on that first day when you're on the
bench and you're saying i could come on
like i might just get it yeah it's
different for everyone i don't think
that sort of i don't think that
feeling of uncomfort that uncomfortable
feeling left me till i was probably late
into my 20s and then in the tunnel that
adrenaline rush was always there that
feeling if you're in the tunnel the team
are there next year you're going out and
you've got to make sure you do
everything you can to win that football
match
[Music]
justin do you say best bit of advice
things that stick in my mind it might be
little think constant things that were
there all the time
you know every time you're the hardest
thing to do is when you're in a big
pressurized atmosphere as a defender
is get on the ball and get us playing
you know people say bravery is winning a
tackle or jumping up for a header or
making sure you're in a 50 50 whatever
it might be
the hardest thing to do is going away to
anfield splitting your back four getting
your full backs wide getting your
goalkeeper to give you the ball and play
and try and quiet in that crowd and
scolds it every single time our keeper
got the ball
gas get wide i always remember those
words gaz get wide because i might think
well let's just kick it forward let's
just play up the field a little bit
let's be pragmatic in the first part of
the game we always say get right and
that was him saying we're going to get
on the ball we're going to play
so that's a great bit of advice i think
because it always was it meant that the
standards of our team were that we
always played rio ferdinand before every
match i played with him said nothing
down our side nothing down our side he
was right center back i was right back
and i wanted those words because i knew
that if anything came down our side it
was either me or him that were at fault
so nothing down our side
we're not giving goals away we didn't
give goals away course we'd make
mistakes
but those words before a game reminded
me what i'm there to do roy key might
say concentration if you make if your
first touch is bad or if you're you know
concentrate you you become alert you
step up so it's there's not these
magical words that you know i said
before about the boss they're really
things principles that work for you
every single day of your life that you
just remember and that you abide by when
you're playing
um yeah
they're the things that i always
remember
[Music]
biggest regret
if i speak to my two daughters it'll say
definitely not scoring more goals they
think it's absolute embarrassment that
scored seven goals and six hundred and
two good can't get rid around it like
seven goals in 602 games absolute
shambles fullback's changed as a
position though though he does but i
missed so many chances i should have
been braver i should have paid more
attention to it not saying i'd have
scored 100 goals i would never even go
near it but yeah that that's not regret
but it's something that always gets
thrown at me by my daughters the biggest
regret like is there a specific incident
do you think england's england
england
never get into a final never winning a
tournament that's a that's a regret it's
a it's my disappointment it's the one
that thing that you know not saying we
could have won every tournament we
certainly couldn't but there's one or
two where i think we could have
performed a lot better and got into
finals and if we had that ruthless
clinical edge to us something missing i
don't know what it was but that's the
big that's the thing that always sticks
with me with united
honestly i couldn't have given any more
at any point in
any second of any day i generally feel
that it's not bragging it's not being
arrogant i genuinely gave my all
how can you regret if you give your all
you know if you work as hard as you
possibly can and you don't give in
then how can you have regrets
how can you have regrets then thinking
of england there you say like so which
which of those teams that fills you with
the mushroom which are those like
tournaments 96 in 2004 maybe 2006 but
2496 those two euros
and these lads they've just lost this
final to italy on penalties who were
absolutely outstanding it will live with
them forever
honestly losing a penalty shootout in
the semi-final final like they have
which is an unbelievable achievement
i've got a bad word to say about them
well done to them and they're a great
team they'll it will live with them
honestly it will live with them they'll
always have that feeling prefer
something like that what's the squad
what's it like in that dressing room
when when you've gone through or just
been that close to being a final it's
like what's the dressing room like after
an event like that solemn
yeah i mean players in tears
i never cried after a game of football
never cried after game of football in my
life i still don't now it's a horrible
feeling to walk off that pitch
knowing that that two years of work that
you've put in all those fans that have
traveled are in that stadium and there's
always tens of thousands of them
wherever we are
they're all going home devastated and
you're into that dressing room and
you've got to go back to your team hotel
and pack your bag
and you've got to leave each other
having been together for a month like a
family it's a horrible feeling
it's a horrible feeling packing that bag
after you've been knocked out
particularly it's a disappointing one
and there was some of them
is
a brutal feeling you know i experienced
it a lot
what's the moment you look back on with
the most like it fills you with the most
joy
barcelona probably last minute you know
to win the european cup
um after so long it was the boss's
dream
it was our dream um but to win the
treble to win the league the fa cup and
the champions league in 10 days
and the way we won it i think it
epitomised how i see
a manchester united player among the
united team you just fight to the
absolute death you everything to win i
don't care what it is
you have to try and win ev every cost
and
that team just went and went and never
stopped never stopped it was
it was brick car to that team so let's
let's put put us in your shoes that
night in barcelona when it happened when
the moment so when when we when i mean
out of fantasy but when you know
equalize
you're on the pitch still are you are
you still you're stolen aren't you at
that point yeah can you remember when
you see it we should michael go up were
you in the box for the cross from no so
i i don't if you remember i ended up on
the left wing right to get the
i put a long throwing in
it ball got played back out and it got
played over to me and i played across
into the box they got deflected out for
the corner
so i then went back it was on the left
wing just i ran over there sprinted over
there just to sort of take the long
throw which sometimes i would do
in desperation when we needed to win a
game and had the long throw in the team
so just get it in the box
and then from that i knew i was the one
back me and dennis were always back on
the halfway line the one thing i
remember in that game and i played in
the new camp before but i'd never
recognized it obviously with being so
full of manchester united fans at that
end that we were sort of kicking towards
and the bayern munich fans were behind
us here
but i thought all those people i
remember thinking this in the game
sometimes
these things would happen to me or i
think you know the cr i was aware of the
crowd sometimes you're not you're just
in a game but i sometimes was aware of
the crowd i felt the crowd were part of
the entertainment i always clap them
before a game i always clap them after a
game every single time i was thinking
they've not celebrated they've not even
seen a goal and i'm gonna have to go
over there and clap them at the end
and they're all gonna go home
and that goal went in and they just all
went absolutely mad i don't know how
many words there were there was about 40
000 of them
and i thought right and you start get
goosebumps and you think something's
happening and then you think in extra
time you're thinking right let's get to
extra time there's no one in our team
thinking score a winning goal no one can
be
you know you've just got a goal you're a
leaf is is enormous and the second goal
goes in
and literally i'm planked on the floor
on my back
literally i think i actually nearly went
into tears
i was emotional screaming and to be fair
even now i feel quite emotional about it
cause i just thought oh my god
what have you lot just done
yeah i mean what have you thought just
in my first words to ollie you have no
idea what you've just done
honestly you've just created history in
that moment
and i remember sort of just lying on the
floor
and not getting up and you'll never see
me in any celebration in that far corner
when they're all i'm literally on the
halfway length i'm back for the corner
on the floor lying back like that
looking up to the sky
and i'm not really just i don't go to
church but i'm just looking up thinking
what has just happened it was like
mind-blowing and can you remember what
happens next did you picked up by
someone and told we gotta play gotta
finish the game i think i think to be
fair remember david beckham coming back
to the halfway line he was on the right
at this point
and i remember us just thinking
we've done it it's it you know it's
happened it's like in juventus when um
i think coley scores that goal that
third goal and i remember thinking we've
done it we've you know you got to the
final and then obviously you know
they're not going to come back from that
and the referee blew his whistle
literally a matter of seconds after the
kickoff again
and it was just at that point absolute
mayhem i then remember us all sitting on
the pitch singing sit down from james
which obviously is on camera and
thinking wow i remember scalzi and
keaney coming through with the suits on
absolutely blathered
been drinking all day you know i mean
just had two in there
and then i remember the next thing i
remember is walking around
on my own
um
the port in barcelona
with champagne at seven o'clock in the
morning thinking i ain't going to bed
and it's the i think it's the only time
in my life i've never gone to bed and i
couldn't go to bed there's nothing going
to get me to sleep
we were on such an adrenaline rush and
it hit me about nine o'clock the next
night
and literally i was gone and then i'm
coming down dean's gate and seeing the
fans and thinking i've never seen
anything like this in my life it was the
fans it was the
it was the emotion of the fans it was
the sort of
i know i know what manchester united
means to our fans i know it
i lived it i am one
but i've never seen it like that i
always recall veins popping out a grown
men's necks
you know men and women hanging off
scaffold pulse and tubes and lamp posts
you know risking
you know injury great injury just to see
us
and the feeling of like
complete and utter emotion and
happiness i never look back i'm looking
back now but i never look back in my
life i'm always thinking what's going
head forward but if i could live 10 days
again in my life or a period in my life
it would just be that 10 days even if
you gave me that 24 hours
maybe from sort of all his goal
even to the walker you know walking on
the beach in barcelona i mean no wonder
you get i'm getting goosebumps just must
be just hearing about it again it must
be such a thing to even think of with
that moment just build you with such
pride it does because it it just at the
time you don't realize you do realize it
that actually one way you do realize it
sometimes you achieve things and you
don't realize it as a team i think at
that moment we realized that something
was special and you're something
for that team it's probably never the
same again you know the manager had to
rebuild in the mid 2000s and get to 2008
with a new group of younger players you
know vidic
uh ferdinand undercover evra rooney
ronaldo players like that so there was a
turnover yeah scolsi was still there and
giggs he was still there but
it was a new team
and once you ever reach that level as
much as i would always say standards
remain the same all the time it's
difficult after that one
for everybody to recover from it people
think you need to recover from defeat
sometimes
a great victory you need to recover from
that as well
[Music]
i remember teammates getting into
disputes i remember teammates coming to
blows i remember incidents of
with myself
at times
how did you fight with it i think to be
fair once i remember rude van nistelrooy
at middlesbrough way he was fuming with
me came in after the game i i was
already in the dressing room i played a
ball in the channel he'd not run for it
it was probably a bad ball but i want
him to run after bad balls i used to say
make a good make it bad and they're good
and you know what i mean that was sparky
just put it in there i'll make it a good
and so i was like you know put it in
there rude just run after it you know
try and
try and uh close down the defender do
something for me don't make him look an
idiot and he wanted a better pass which
to be fair and fair use to him as well
he didn't want it he didn't wonder
chasing down channels from for my for my
uh agricultural uh hikes uh and yeah
just about that you're something i never
let things continue i never let things
continue with anybody i always got over
it and they always got over it and i was
confronted either after the game or
certainly on the monday morning when we
were back in do you have to get on with
your teammates because i know there's
the famous examples of people like i'm
sharing him in cold didn't particularly
get on well or something out there does
that add a difficult dynamic in a
dressing room do you know something i
think no you don't have to always get on
with your teammates
and that means that in 21 22 players in
the dressing room you know player six
might not get home with player 12 and
that might never come to the four and it
might be something that you don't even
recognize but they just don't see eye to
eye to eye or they don't go out with
each other they don't speak to each
other that much
but for me i always feel like i had to
be able to have a conversation with
every single player in the dress room at
united i didn't want to be any of them
that i couldn't go over and speak to
because i felt i felt uncomfortable then
so that every player that i think i
played with and there might be the odd
one that comes out and says well no he
never spoke to me but i'd be surprised
um there was one or two players i'm not
the name that i wasn't great fans of
because i thought they were actually i
thought they were a risk to us
our spirit
our energy
i would never comment on performance
because i wasn't always great i just
felt they weren't great in the dressing
room a couple of players and to prefer
the manager moved them on quite quickly
they weren't with the club for long
periods
um but i i always felt like i needed to
get on with the rest of the dressing
room
um because i think we were
you know me my brother
you know butty giggsy we were when we
were coming through
in in a period we were sort of the ones
that you could we could have a go at
them they could have a go us type thing
and you need those sort of what would be
yeah you need that sort of glue in the
dressing room and then when i got a
little bit more experienced it became
wayne rooney it became patrice evra
and rio ferdinand they were the energy
in the dressing room because they were
younger and they just had that sort of
incredible spirit between them but we
could see it that we used to have that
five six years before and i'm sure when
sharpie and giggsy and insie were
younger and they were coming through
tonight they had that same spirit for
the likes of
you know brucey and and robo and pally
and then play so your young players are
always your ones in the dress room you
feel like you gotta have that energy um
you've got energy in the dressing room
and you've got enthusiasm and that sort
of feeling that you want to come into
that dressing room every single day so
yeah i think you can have one or two
that don't quite get on but generally
the dressing room most of you've got to
be able to be tolerant of each other and
accept each other and that doesn't go in
the dressing room that goes for anything
that you're doing in your life
i'm going to ask you know about like two
specific incidents that people have
talked about that happened in the mayan
dressing room and i just want to get
your kind of memory of what happened and
what was the outcome from the first one
is is pizzagate uh seth fabregas
so what can you take us through that
incident where you were like you did
with the champions league final earlier
on we talked about that where were you
and what actually happened do you
remember happening
joseph in the tunnel say the tunnel at
manchester united it wasn't the tunnel
it was the corridor to the changing
rooms it was so tight you're talking
about probably a meter wide maybe 1.2
meters wide you know that
and then you've got about 20 odd people
all in a corridor and it was just a
mayhem it was just a load of noise of
shouting of balling of
aggro that always used to spill over
against arsenal if there was an incident
during the game if we lost them we were
upset or they lost and they were upset i
think obviously now it's you know it's a
well told story that i think it was
fabregas that basically threw the pizza
we used to put pizzas in the dressing
room about obviously the way team and
ourselves after a game he's gone in
and he's come back out so what's
happening he started loving pizzas and
stuff i mean that's strange thing to do
but easter i'm not against it i always
felt that all was always fair
in love or more in football i always
felt you know if fans criticized me if
they sang my name in a derogatory man i
always felt it was fair because i would
call it on with them and i always felt
that's how it should be a football game
is competitive and it should be
competitive within boundaries off the
pitch and there should be that energy
intention in a stadium that's there good
energy and tension and that existed
between the teams
i i was still brought up in an era
and i know it's different now and it's
right to be different and you know
but i was brought up in an area whereby
you couldn't like the opposition
why would you why would i like that why
would i shake answer them in the
dressing room why would i look at my
brother when i'm walking out with him
for his everton captain why would he
look at me why would the shape pitch
michael's hand when he's gone played for
manchester city
wow duh i see pleasure in conversations
they're hugging each other and it's it's
wonderful and i i'm glad the game can be
paid in that spirit and still be as
competitive and compelling as it is but
that could never have happened with our
dressing room our dressing room wasn't
built like that it it you couldn't you
had to alex ferguson there
you had roy keane as captain for the
majority of my career and you had
underneath roy keane a group of players
who were manchester united fans in the
core of the dressing room who didn't
like anybody else
he didn't like anybody else you're
brought up not to like anybody else
that's what you are he's your club is it
weird then to go from like this sort of
hatred might be too strong a word but
where you don't want to you want to beat
them you want absolutely hammer them to
them when you retire and you become a
pundit and you're starting to like
interact with these people on a
different level yeah
i never thought i wondered what it would
be like obviously when i finished my
career
and i had to go work on television with
players that are essentially not not
going with yeah jamie carragher is
famously and there's no doubt that if i
was at sky for two three years before
you know i was doing monday night
football if i'd have said
you know i don't want him to come in it
may have influenced skype time but i
would never do that
you know i was bigger than that and i
always would say no i think the we've
always got to have the best for the show
for what we're doing we've always got to
have the best what we're doing whatever
so if i'm at sky now i want the best
production the best studio i want the
best pundits in there i want us to
give great entertainment you have to so
i always think that way and i have to
say that it became quite obvious within
12 months
that i was going to have to adapt and
change about all the anger left me the
second i left united which was the
second i finished my career the anger
left me
the tension left me the you know if you
think about me i never smiled for 20
years on the football pitch
i never smiled i never i never once saw
football as a joy and then when i left
football
i could become me and i could sort of
get rid of that and am i a winner now no
i'm not
i don't go to any football match and
think i used to take it home with me at
night used to ruin my week as it all did
all of us
but now if united lose i'm disappointed
and i'm annoyed but
for an hour or two that night maybe and
then i wake up in the morning in the
past but i've forgotten about it because
i can't do anything about it
who would you say are the top six now if
it's if lester are in there who's
dropped out well liverpool are in there
united are in their city in chelsea are
in there
tottenham and leicester in the last few
years i would say arsenal fans will
probably like come with some stat now
that you know i mean because i think i
ate them anyway